so this isn't going to be like
generating sounds and cool stuff like
that you can find those on the internet
this is going to be
kind of ranty
i hope i don't make the mics crackle
so
my name is blaine bublitz
you can find me on github at faded
if you can't remember that it's fat ed
and uh
i
started a company
it's not last december this december
before with my business partner louis
you might have saw us talk earlier it's
called ice dev we do javascript
consulting and html5 gaming
we're always looking for awesome fun
projects so if you have anything hit me
up
we also have fantastic shirts to give
away
limited edition
and
i want to give all of them away so find
me and and take a shirt um
we have an open source game engine
called frozen js
and we've been working on it really hard
for the last five months we've put out
four versions in that time
and we're really proud of it
we want to actually start like making
games for money but right now we're
consulting um go use it
submit issues tell us what's wrong with
it stuff like that we also have awesome
stickers that look like that so get them
too
and i run hackathons in phoenix where
i'm from
and
we did an html5 game hackathon in
december arduino in march and if you
want to have awesome time and you're in
phoenix or close to phoenix you should
definitely come out because we have tons
of prizes and
also always looking for sponsors
so
gather round everybody while i tell you
a story
of ancient times when the proprietary
ones ruled the world
and made us do horrible things like
embed and object
until one day the html5 warriors
vanquished them
and delivered unto us
multimedia
most of you explored the sunny lands of
the audio and video tag
but very few ventured into things such
as web audio and codex and mobile
i decided to take on this challenge so i
don my adventurer's gear
and before i even began my quest the
great wizard deltonius uttered these
words to me
sound will age you
uh
i told him that i was going to be
working on sound and
he was right
sounds are important we can all agree
that sounds are important
if you've ever watched a movie or a tv
show or play the game with the sound off
it's not the same
when i was little i was scared of chucky
so i turned off the uh i muted it and
it's just a stupid doll running around
with a knife in his hand it's kind of
funny actually
and i didn't plug in the speaker thing
so we're going to do this really loud
uh i kind of wanted to play a game uh
sounds are iconic
if you can hear these and you know them
shout out what you think they are
all right
sonic nice
i'm gonna die and there's pac-man out
there yeah
mega man dying yes so we all rec well a
lot of us recognize them uh
they they really they bring you back to
a moment they bring you back to memories
sounds are iconic and they they add a
lot
um sounds are also very hard
ask anybody that does sound
not just in the browser but sounds are
hard
um
i don't know why we haven't made it why
we haven't made it easier
so my perspective is from frozen js
which we've been working on
so it's coming from a games perspective
a lot of this talk will be influenced by
that
and hopefully you can take it and apply
it to web apps stuff like that
but i just wanted to point out that it's
towards games i guess
so let's take a look at like i said web
audio versus html5 audio like how to
implement kind of the same things in
each codex how to deal with codecs
that's
you'll see
and mobile
and that's where the ranting comes in so
so the first implementation of frozen uh
it had a sound implementation but
uh
it was just web audio so
that was like the best before this
that's the technology that we want to
use
um
but
it didn't have any fallbacks or not
nothing happened if you didn't have web
audio
so
uh my partner louis implemented it at
the first implementation and he did
something really he did something right
right he started with web audio like
this technology that they've developed
for for us for for games and stuff it
says in spec
he did something horribly horribly
horribly wrong
he only implemented web audio
and expected that the browser vendors
actually
cared enough to get it out quickly
um so you can see
uh by this can i use thing that chrome
has had it for a long time
and it just got into safari and ios
safari which is really cool and it looks
like it's coming in firefox it's
actually a nightly unflagged right now
and who knows about ie it might it might
not i don't know
and there's bugs open for firefox
android uh i i definitely encourage you
to go there plus one them at least show
people or show the browser vendors that
we are that we want them that we need
them or that we need these apis
so if we start with web audio what do we
get
things like very high performance um low
latency so like you can fire
a thousand times a second right like
just crazy amounts of sound processing
and and playing and all this stuff
it actually uses buffers instead of uh
resource loading so so the html5 audio
tag goes through a resource loading
process
and streams the the data down and plays
it but uh web audio if we're just going
to play a sound it we grab the whole
buffer and
and uh we know when we have it and stuff
so start with web audio but fall back
like i said he did something horribly
wrong the browser vendors don't move as
fast as we would like
and to
make games and apps we want to support
browsers so
do fall back to html5 audio for browser
support
i just wanted to show you some of the
things that you would want to do in web
web audio and then that you can fall
back on html5 audio
uh it's things like initializing like
preparing right it's getting your new
audio context it's actually prefixed
right now in in chrome and safari so
it's webkit audio context
hopefully they move away from that and
then html5 audio you're just newing up
an audio object i like this syntax
better than document.createelement audio
so use this one instead
to load a resource for web audio like i
said we have to get this buffer ahead of
time
and
then after we have the buffer we can
decode it into our audio stream
or
yeah
um and
then we can use it so we just make an
ajax request out we grab it
you just have to make sure that your
response type is array buffer if it's
not
shit's going to get [ __ ] man
and
then when we get it back we just pass it
to the decode audio data
and we'll get a buffer
and that'll that does it async so you
have to do your two callbacks one for on
air or on success and on air
that's how you load an html5
audio tag uh set its source
um and it starts downloading because
preload is set to true by default
to play it you um for web audio you
create a buffer source you got to have
some place to stick this buffer now that
you have it and then you just connect it
to a destination that's like speakers
and and and uh headphones uh your
browser your audio context keeps track
of that and then you just want to start
it you start it on a
a second so
that's how you play in web audio just to
note note on is the old api and i
believe that safari
only supports the old api
html5 audio is just calling
play for volume again it's a little more
complicated because like web audio has
this um
node system and you just plug nodes
together so you're actually creating a
gain which is like a volume thing um
connecting your source to that so that
it knows about this the volume and then
you take the volume node and connect
that to the destination instead of the
source directly because otherwise it's
just the default uh level
and then you can just set the gain value
and that changes to the volume and html5
audio just volume
so you're probably saying like that's so
complicated why is there so much
boilerplate for uh web audio
it's really because they they
implemented this
the api so that they can extend it later
like they really paid attention to the
the whole node thing so they can add a
new node and just plug it in
um
but so if it's so complicated why we
want to do it we get a ton of extras so
yeah we can fall back for those simple
things but we can't do things like we
can't create sounds in the html5 audio
tag
we
don't have transitions it's just like
cut it off start another one and you
can't do any kind of processing or
anything on the fly so
web audio is definitely the best
way to go
and like i said future features stuff
like that
so i guess the goal is to turn this
into that
and i think i have a link at the end to
go go to this it's pretty cool
all right so let's talk about codex
this is a pain point not not as big as
the next one but
you can see all the not supported i hope
you can see how they're not supported
there is a lot
it is not fun at all if you notice
ie does not support wave
all right moving on
so
something that you can use so they they
expose this api as part of the spec
we can check if our browser can play a
codec
it the function is called can play type
all right so yeah that's a cool that's a
cool function name
but
i don't know about you all you but i
don't like getting strings back from my
functions that say maybe or probably
um
like zero to one come on we have
floating points
uh so
if it if the browser thinks it maybe can
play it he returns maybe if it thinks
that it probably can play like what does
that even mean i i don't know
um
like why can uh so webm only has one
kodak right now so why is that a maybe
if it doesn't have that codec it
shouldn't be able to play
so i
i don't like it
but it's in the spec
so to get full browser support
because ie doesn't support wave
we need mp3
and everybody likes mp3s
mp3s are supported by chrome i.e safari
some of the firefoxes like weird edge
things like
if it's a brand new firefox on a
platform that has mp3 codec installed
it'll go out to the operating system and
use it but it doesn't come with it so
that's a big pain so expect to use webm
or og on firefox
also chromium does not have it
so if you if if any of you use chromium
you don't have mp3s
and opera doesn't and that'll be based
off chromium so it still won't
and like i said chrome safari they also
support this stuff but
ie is the main thing so you probably
want to start with mp3
so how do we decide which codec to pick
and use to to play our sound
we can have an array that has both of
our sounds in it with a different
type a different type and a different
extension
um if we start with mp3 as the first one
and webm has the second one we can just
go or we can just iterate over them
returning early of course when we hit
one that doesn't return empty string we
check if it can play type and then we
just assign it to the source
and i have comments at the bottom
telling like what browsers would have
which extension
and all of my examples um i just did a
fiddle and then i kept building on the
fiddle so
like
the links are at the bottom
so what if we
try to do an mp3
when it tells us maybe
and it doesn't work
it just errors out like big error
is horrible
but we can listen for the error event
and if we do that we can then filter out
our current ones since we know it
errored
and we can
try the next one right so we filter it
out and then we just do our same
iteration over and get the next one
that's available
if you're doing a bunch of like
different codecs because of file size or
whatever
that this is very helpful because you
just keep trying
so i said we had maybe and i said we had
probably
and now we're catching errors
but
the errors happen after we try to get
something so we're doing a round trip to
the server
which sucks
so what we probably want to do is try
all the probabilities first
then try all the maybes
so what we can do is we can go over our
whole array of sounds
find all the probably's put them at the
beginning of our of a new array find all
the maybes and shove them at the end
anything that gives us an empty string
just ignore it
and then
our
set source kind of becomes a little
easier and we also don't need a filter
um so you then you do set source and you
just shift off and
you're trying all the probably's then
you try all the maybes
so that's really that's that's good
that's
the least likely to make a second round
trip to the server
which is good
turn it into a function call it load um
it just moves up an audio object injects
the file name into our array and gives
us all of that boilerplate we just wrote
and then it returns the audio object out
so then we can just call play and we
know that we have one that that's either
working or completely didn't work at all
so in frozen
we have some plugins and when we use
them to manage resources
i was really proud i had a lot of fun
with and i'm really proud of like the
load sound implementation
plug-in
uh it
defaults to web audio sounds
if you don't have web audio it falls
back to html5 audio if you don't have
html5 audio it falls back to an uh
no opt version like a uh just empty play
and empty
load all this stuff so you can just
write the same code
uh and
if you call this extension
with a file name without and if you call
this plugin with a file name without an
extension
it will auto
uh complete the extension so it will do
the maybes or the probabilities then the
maybes and get you the best sound
all right so
done with codex
what do you guys expect play to do
all right and load
all right
me too
so
these are the specs and i just copied
and pasted them because
it's the spec
you can see media load supposed to load
media play is supposed to
load if it's not loaded and play
it's supposed to load
we don't need no stinking spec here
chrome
works chrome loads chrome plays
firefox plays loads
i.e even plays and loads
opera safari
how about mobile safari
no
what
chrome on android
no
there is hope though firefox on android
it plays and loads and firefox os plays
and look what
what's wrong with this
you guys
lost all of it
it was beautiful
anyways there's beautiful
beautiful
logos up there
um so ios is excuse on their like
developer documentation
copied and pasted i don't care if you
read all that but read that
god yeah
read this
so preload and autoplay are disabled
javascript play and load methods are
also inactive until the user initiates
playback
so in my javascript that i wrote on my
webpage that a user chose to go to i
cannot play
or load a sound
without them touching the page
and then android
on the same bandwagon
it's intended was their response to a
bug
and then 30 days later that bug was
closed
so then somebody opened another issue
saying the exact same thing
and there's the source of that quote
i in my other slides where i point to
the body i point to the new bug
it will cost data usage
remember that quote we will get back to
it
meanwhile
you can download terabytes
of images unrestricted
try it
and don't even display the images just
download them in the background
okay so they're going to stick us with
this weird requirement that's offspec
and terrible so how do we work around it
we do uh we bind to touch start because
we're on mobile because mobile is the
problem
and we call load
we so we intercept this user interaction
and then we just remove it because we
only need to do it once
per audio element
you can't do it on one and then it works
for all of them it's each individual one
all right so this is our workaround this
is what they tell us to do
so
all is good right
we intercept
user input and this
these sounds are loaded
but nothing is actually how it seems
you intercept user input and call load
and it loads them a second time that
means
on chrome on android it already loaded
them
it
they are saving data usage
by already loading
the files and telling you that they
don't load
so we can do better because we now know
this because i thought that i could
write some code and it would work the
way i thought and then i debugged it and
it wasn't
we can set the volume to zero
we can play the sound so that it doesn't
load
and then we can pause the sound
immediately
then we can turn the volume back up
is it solved
it's actually as solved as we can get it
so uh
there's still late there there's still
some latency
uh because it pulls it it feels like it
pulls down some but not all or something
it's weird like this doesn't give you a
lot of information as you can see it
doesn't even show uh that it's loaded it
like shows pending
and it doesn't and even uh when you call
load it doesn't show load loaded so
there's weird and it's still latent so
that's the best we can do but at least
we're not loading things twice which is
good for the user right
all right so
we have a new hope
and that is disable
gesture requirement for media playback
yes
do it
uh if you have chrome
on on chrome for android uh you can go
and enable this and do it please please
please please please it will make
everybody's life easier uh
and hopefully because they have this
this uh
this flag now i'm hoping that they
actually uh try to move that into
unflagged
which is a good thing
so i can't go whole talk without talking
about streams you know like there's this
node thing
and like they say streams
i'm just kidding
so
audio stream so so audio streams are
like playing once out and playing
another sound at the same time right
um i'm getting really close to the end
and um
so we want to layer these sounds right
we want to create us a kind of a
a sound scene of like person walking and
a clock ticking and a gun firing right
we want to layer all these things and
make an immersive experience we need it
like that's how you make a good game
on mobile
no
you start playing a sound
and then you start playing another sound
and it cuts you off
the first one
and then you play another one it cuts it
off and these are individual elements or
like separate elements it's not the same
one that you're playing again it's a
totally different one it just cuts it
off
it's
like we cannot create html5 games
or even like really good web apps that
that need sound for emerging without
fixing these fundamental things on
mobile
and there's no reason for them to be
there firefox doesn't have them
there is hope again
the return of the jed i mean web audio
it is in chrome again in chrome beta 28
so install it and enable it again flags
are awesome
web audio they let you play as many
streams as you want at the same time and
it it feels fantastic uh
some of the games that we wrote actually
are amazing now on mobile because you
can actually hear the sounds
so we're much better than before
we need sound like i said we need for
immersion feedback uh feedback like if
you shoot a gun you might not see a
bullet fly out but you'll hear it right
and brand recognition like uh those
sounds at the beginning the iconic
sounds right
seg
stuff like that
sounds are that's why we need them
so we start with web audio
for all the awesome reasons that i
already said
we fall back to html5 audio because it's
there on pretty much everything and it
can get us kind of the way there
there are some or some uh
trade-offs
don't fall back to flash we all know
that flash sucks we're javascripters
there's no support on mobile pretty much
right and on desktop it's a resource hog
why do you want the fan spinning up for
a web browser game for your user you
don't
if at all possible
so let's push web audio instead don't do
flash screw that don't write libraries
for that push web audio go
comment on the issues and plus one them
and get get get them to get that in
there faster and enable it in chrome
it's awesome
there's still areas we need to improve
like i bitched about android and ios
enough we need to fix those
um can play type like maybe it should be
a floating point zero to one
um
and we need some better abstractions for
like web audio and like even creating
sounds stuff like that there's some cool
stuff out there uh such as this awesome
list i found howler actually uh right as
those finish up the talk it looks really
nice and then there's some that are not
not fallback libraries but uh actually
let you do the some of the sound
creation and stuff
uh some game engines with good sound
implementations uh i have to say frozen
because i did it
sound.js looks excellent i actually
found that one while researching or
making my slides i'll probably be taking
a lot of their advice
issues
go participate go forth and participate
some tutorials and stuff to get you off
the ground with web audio
the specs because everybody likes
reading specs
yeah images and
i'm playing
all my awesome links
and that's where my slide deck is at
thanks
you